klimastreit im schnee dünn beim
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos bezeichnet
donald trump umweltaktivisten als
untergangspropheten greta thunberg wirft
den mächtigen versagen vor
immer mehr menschen mit mehreren jobs
die zahl der sogenannten multi jobber
hat sich in deutschland seit 2004
verdoppelt und auftaktsieg nach langem
tief alexander zverev kämpft sich bei
den australian open in die zweite runde
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
dienstag den sport in etwa 15 minuten
präsentiert norbert lehmann ganz schön
ein tor von mir
es sei der versuch die po die zukunft
positiv zu gestalten so erklärt davos
gründer klaus schwab die idee des
weltwirtschaftsforums zum fünfzigsten
mal hat er eingeladen und den
klimawandel als zentrale herausforderung
für die welt in den fokus gestellt
gut bewacht ist der kleine schweizer
skiort jetzt wieder vier tage lang
schauplatz welt politische diskussionen
mit dabei sind rund 3000
konferenzteilnehmer regierungschefs
wirtschaftsbosse und organisationen und
schon am ersten tag zeigen diese beiden
redner
unterschiedlicher könnten die meinungen
kaum sein
stefan leifert es ist schon das zweite
mal dass donald trump in davos ein
schwebt aber zum ersten mal als
präsident unter impeachment druck
während sich die präsidenten kolonne den
weg zum konferenzzentrum band ist der
ton dort schon längst gesetzt generation
geräte hat das weltwirtschaftsforum fest
im griff
es geht hier nicht um rechts oder links
eure parteipolitik interessiert uns
nicht aus einer perspektive der
nachhaltigkeit haben alle parteien egal
ob rechts links oder in der mitte
versagt die rede trumps gerät zum
wahlkampfauftritt gerichtet ans publikum
zu hause
er preist die wirtschaftlichen großtaten
seiner regierung hat für das klima
anliegen nur spott um die chancen von
morgen zu ergreifen müssen wir die
andauernden propheten des jüngsten
gerichts zurückweisen und deren
prophezeiungen der apokalypse
sie haben das gehabe der albernen
märchenerzähler von gestern die es bei
euch genauso gibt wie bei uns sie wollen
uns scheitern sehen aber das werden wir
nicht zulassen
kaum ein wort mehr zur klimadebatte der
applaus am ende verhalten die reaktionen
verwundert bis entsetzt
so treffen in davos klimawandel leugner
auf klimawandel gestalter hier
beansprucht europa die führungsrolle
wir wissen dass wir das ausbauen müssen
erstens wegen des klimas aber zweitens
auch dass wenn der rest der welt folgt
dass wir diejenigen sind die neue
technologien exportieren die das wissen
haben bis freitag noch bietet da wo ist
die kulisse für ein treffen das 50 jahre
alt wird und noch nie so im zeichen
eines einzigen themas stand wie
schwierig klimaschutz sein kann zeigt
sich am kohle ausstieg in deutschland
vor einem jahr hatten hatte die aus
allen betroffenen zusammengesetzte kohle
kommission mühsam einen kompromiss
ausgehandelt
doch die umsetzung der bundesregierung
vorgestellt vor einer woche treibt jetzt
die klimaschützer in der kommission auf
die barrikaden
sie sprechen von verrat und
klimapolitischen irrsinn winnie heescher
diese einigkeit ist dahin
vor einem jahr sah es so aus als könnten
klimaschützer konzerne gewerkschaften
und politik alte gräben überwinden als
kohle kommission präsentierten sie der
kanzlerin gemeinsam einen plan zum
kohleausstieg heute bleibt einigen von
ihnen nur der blick zurück im zorn
ich fühle mich sowohl von der
bundeskanzlerin als auch von den
mitfahrenden denn als auch von den
ministerpräsidenten die die
entsprechenden druck aufgebaut haben
schlichtweg betrogen betrogen vor allem
durch den zeitplan für den braunkohle
ausstieg die kommission hatte
vorgeschlagen schnell mit dem ausstieg
zu beginnen und stetig bis ende 20 38 zu
reduzieren
die bundesregierung aber hat entschieden
zunächst einige alte kraftwerke
abzuschalten
den hauptteil erst später mehr co2
emissionen fürchten dadurch die kritiker
geschätzt 40 millionen tonnen um sich
das klar zu machen 40 millionen tonnen
sind so viel wie die bayerische
industrie in vier jahren emittiert mehr
emissionen fürchten die kritiker auch
bei der steinkohle stichwort datteln 4
die bundesregierung will das neue
kraftwerk trotz ausstiegsbeschluss noch
ans netz gehen lassen
zum ausgleich andere er abschalten das
bedeutet aus unserer sicht dass wir
weniger co2 emittieren werden nicht mehr
deshalb war dieser kompromiss vertretbar
zumal die betreiber von datteln 4 einen
rechtlichen anspruch auf inbetriebnahme
haben die enttäuschten kritiker hoffen
auf nachbesserungen
noch ist der kohleausstieg nicht gesetz
nach china
dort breitet sich die neuartige
lungenkrankheit weiter aus nach
behördenangaben gibt es jetzt fast 300
krankheitsfälle sechs infizierte starben
bisher
experten gehen mittlerweile davon aus
dass das corona virus von mensch zu
mensch übertragbar ist die genaue
herkunft des virus ist noch unklar
das robert koch institut stuft die
gefahr für menschen in deutschland durch
den erreger als gering ein
seit monaten wird darüber diskutiert in
diesen minuten geht es im us-senat in
die entscheidende runde
das amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen
präsident donald job im senat haben die
republikaner von jump die mehrheit sie
wollen das verfahren möglichst schnell
über die bühne bringen und am ende
natürlich einen freispruch
die demokraten fordern vor allem
tieferen einblick einblick in dokumente
und mehr zeit für zeugenaussagen ines
trams berichtet aus washington ein
kleines grüppchen demonstriert vor dem
senat für präsident trumps amtsenthebung
gleich zu beginn wird es hier im senat
streit geben über die spielregeln der
verhandlung die republikaner mit ihrer
mehrheit haben über lange prozesstage
festgelegt ganz so wie trump es will ein
schnelles verfahren die demokraten
entsetzt regeln sind eine nationale
schande
es wird in die geschichte eingehen als
eine sehr dunkle stunde
wenn der senat seiner verantwortung
nicht gerecht wird und nur dem
präsidenten huldigt nicht der wahrheit
auch zeugen wie kam's ehemaligen
sicherheitsberater bolton wollen die
demokraten hören unklar aber ob sie als
minderheit im senat das durchsetzen
können
trump ist derweil beim
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos am
liebsten wäre ihm der senat würde die
klage ganz abweisen amt will dies hinter
sich bringen dann anfang februar seine
rede zur lage an die nation halten um
darzulegen was er noch alles vorhat in
den nächsten jahren medienerfahrene
anwälte holte trump sich in sein team
darunter den der vor 20 jahren gegen
präsident clinton ermittelt hat ken star
dazu promi anwalt alan dershowitz sein
argument amtsmissbrauch sei keine
straftat
ich werde gegen eine amtsenthebung
plädieren denn die anklagepunkte
entsprechen nicht den kriterien die der
verfassung vorgibt
in diesen minuten beginnt die
verhandlung im senat schon der erste tag
könnte zeigen wird es ein seriöses
verfahren oder eine farce diesen skandal
und kein ende der neueste fall
mitsubishi die staatsanwaltschaft
frankfurt durchsuchte bundesweit
geschäftsräume des japanischen
autobauers der verdacht illegale
abschalt einrichtungen in dieselmotoren
der abgasnorm euro 5 und 6 es gebe
hinweise so die staatsanwaltschaft dass
die geltenden grenzwerte für stickoxide
zwar auf dem prüfstand jedoch nicht im
realen betrieb eingehalten würden immer
mehr menschen in deutschland haben
mindestens einen nebenjob mehr als 3,5
millionen das sind doppelt so viele wie
vor 20 jahren berichtete die
bundesanstalt für arbeit
nicht jede form von nebenbeschäftigung
ist schon ein sozialer skandal aber es
gibt bereiche da muss uns das sorgen
machen sagt arbeitsminister heim er als
einen job volker dutschek über die
hintergründe
am frühen abend beginnt für diana rte
die dritte schicht an diesem tag wenn
die alleinerziehende mutter von fünf
kindern essen ausliefert hat sie bereits
zwei jobs hinter sich ein als putzfrau
und ein an der supermarktkasse drei jobs
und trotzdem ist das geld knapp
das macht mir schon wütend und
deprimiert dass man mit wirklich harte
arbeit sein leben so mehr schlecht als
recht bestreiten kann
unterm strich bleiben
549 euro übrig und für das geld muss ich
dann halt auch noch einkaufen und paar
sachen für die kinder kaufen und auch
noch ein bisschen tanken
die zahl der multi jobber hat sich in
den vergangenen 15 jahren verdoppelt auf
inzwischen 3,5 millionen menschen
besonders stark die kombination von
sozialversicherungspflichtiger
hauptbeschäftigung mit einem minijob das
machen fast 90 prozent der nebenjob
und das liegt vor allem daran dass sie
bei steuern und abgaben so sehr stark
begünstigt sind der arbeitnehmer kann
nämlich brutto für netto arbeiten was
die menschen in nebenjobs treibt ist
auch der wunsch nach mehr konsum und die
vorstellung sich mal was besonderes was
zusätzliches leisten zu können aber für
die große masse derjenigen die
beispielsweise nachts zeitungen
austragen müssen oder die wahren
einräumen im supermarkt oder die abends
kellnern gehen oder am wochenende
das tun die nicht weil die sich
langweilen oder weil sie das toll finden
sondern schlichtweg aus einer
materiellen not heraus für diana r ziel
ist klar ohne die drei jobs käme sie
derzeit nicht zurecht juden sollen sich
überall in deutschland sicher bewegen
können gerade auch dann wenn sie sich
als juden zu erkennen geben das hat der
antisemitismus beauftragte felix klein
heute betont eigentlich eine
selbstverständlichkeit die realität
sieht nun anders aus immer häufiger
kommt es zu übergriffen und pöbeleien
gerade auch an schulen michael
haselrieder und beate frenkel in berlin
ist liam rückert nur noch in den ferien
hier ist der 16 jährige aufgewachsen und
zur schule gegangen bis er es nicht mehr
ausgehalten hat mitschüler haben
monatelang gemobbt also ich wurde auch
schon oft einfach einfach so scheiß
juden genannt oder chefs rallye also
eine frau ohne grund so
und ich habe mich gewundert warum sich
noch ein mensch williams mutter ist den
kontakt mit anderen jüdischen eltern
deren kindern ist ähnlich erging die
eltern trauen sich nichts zu sagen und
die die sich trauen was zu sagen dann
kommt das kindheit weg das opfer geht
und der täter bleibt antisemitismus in
der schule jüdische gemeinden sind
besorgt dass hat für unserer wahrnehmung
explosionsartig zugenommen
wir erhalten immer mehr berichte von
jungen menschen aus schulen die sagen
sie werden antisemitisch angegangen sie
werden antisemitisch gemobbt der
antisemitismus beauftragte fordert eine
meldepflicht für judenfeindliche
vorfälle an schulen heute hat er das
programm für das festjahr 1700 jahre
jüdisches leben in deutschland
vorgestellt
die besten waffen die wir haben im kampf
gegen antisemitismus sind begegnungen
mit jüdischem leben aufklärung über das
judentum und das bewusstmachen die stark
jüdisches leben auch unser land geprägt
hat liam rück hat geht mittlerweile in
israel in der nähe von tel aviv aufs
internat anders als in deutschland sagt
lira könne er hier ganz offen zeigen
dass er jude ist ohne angst zu haben
mehr über antisemitismus an schulen und
die bedeutung von zeitzeugen sehen sie
heute abend um 9 bei frontal21
dazu passt eine außergewöhnliche
ausstellung die heute von der
bundeskanzlerin eröffnet wurde der titel
survivors überlebende zu sehen sind
porträts wie diese von menschen die den
holocaust überlebt haben der deutsche
fotograf martin schoeller hat sie
getroffen
der anlass vor 75 jahren wurde auschwitz
birkenau befreit das größte deutsche
vernichtungslager carsten edinger
eigentlich fotografiert er prominente
doch diese fotos hier sind seine
emotionalsten martin schiller hat 75
holocaust überlebende in jerusalem
getroffen und sie porträtiert diese
geschichten zu hören man hat das gefühl
alles andere war dass man sich
unterhalten will ist total belanglos in
der essener zeche zollverein werden
seine fotos nun ausgestellt das gesicht
der porträtierten zentriert im bild ihr
blick geradeaus gesichter wie das des
92-jährigen jona bands er überlebte ein
konzentrations und ein arbeitslager
nicht alle aus einer familie hatten
dieses glück mein vater starb in meinen
armen in estland vor hunger und
überarbeitung er starb dort
ich blieb allein zurück
[Musik]
die eröffnung der ausstellung liegt kurz
vorm 75 jahrestag der befreiung des
konzentrationslagers auschwitz einer
befreiung die menschen wie martha wiese
das leben rettete ich war mit meiner
13-jährigen schwester in auschwitz sie
sind doch nicht auf jedem foto doch da
sind wir darauf dass hier ist meine
schwester und das bin ich wir waren zehn
und 13 jahre alt irgendwie haben wir
überlebt es war reines glück wirklich
fotos persönlich und unausweichlich die
holocaust-überlebenden wollen dass man
sie und ihre geschichten wahrnimmt die
ausstellung geht von deutschland aus auf
welttournee
[Musik]
und bis zum 26 april ist sie in der
zeche zollverein in essen zu sehen
teilerfolg für renate künast das
berliner landgericht hat eine
umstrittene entscheidung revidiert
teilweise zumindest
sechs von 22 hass kommentaren auf
facebook erfüllten nun doch den
straftatbestand der beleidigung so die
kammer die grünen politikerin gibt sich
damit aber nicht zufrieden
sie will in der nächsten instanz die
herausgabe aller nutzerdaten erzwingen
im september hatte das gericht noch
entschieden des kühlers übelste hass
kommentare hinnehmen müsse über den
osten spaniens sind schwere unwetter
gezogen mindestens drei menschen kamen
dabei ums leben
der sturm gloria hatte eisigen wind
starken schneefall und intensiven regen
mitgebracht
es kam zu stromausfällen bei valencia
blieben viele schulen geschlossen
straßen und schienenverbindungen waren
unterbrochen
auch in frankreich wohin der sturm jetzt
weiter zieht sind strecken gesperrt
und jetzt zu den australian open norbert
optimaler start für zwei deutsche tennis
ass ja für die zwei deutschen
sorgenkinder sozusagen angelique kerber
ist weiter trotz verletzungen kurz vor
dem turnierstart und alexander zverev
der hat sich aus seinem langen form tief
herausgekämpft durch einen souveränen 13
0 sieg emotionen gehören der alexanders
wäre zum tagesgeschäft auch gegen den
italiener die nato muss der deutsche
phasenweise sein bestes tennis zeigen
sonst hätte es eng werden können
[Applaus]
in allen drei sätzen mit break hinten
und gemacht und das hat mir so ein
bisschen noch mut gegeben in den
entscheidenden phasen dieser partie wäre
auf dem druck stand spielt auch bei
rückständen groß auf am ende steht ein 6
zu 4 7 zu 6 und 6 3 und sollte die
australian open gewinnen will das
preisgeld von 2,5 millionen euro an die
betroffenen der buschbrände spenden
bis dahin aber ist es noch ein weiter
weg große bühne für den breitensport in
berlin zum sechzehnten mal wurde bei der
vergabe der sterne des sports
ehrenamtliches engagement gewürdigt und
zum bundessieger wurde
pfeffer sport gehört ein sportverein der
die gesellschaftliche vielfalt
entsprechen will
unabhängig von alter geschlecht herkunft
oder behindern
gestern abend souveräner sieg der
deutschen handballer gegen österreich
der in die kritik geratene bundestrainer
christian prokop erhält rückendeckung
von der dhb spitze vor dem letzten em
hauptrundenspiel morgen gegen tschechien
der druck auf christian prokop beim
turnier verlauf größer geworden nach der
niederlage samstag gegen kroatien hatte
dhb vizepräsident bob hanning eine
reaktion gefordert die prokops
mannschaft mit dem 34 22 gegen
österreich gezeigt hat wir freuen uns
dass wir mit christian natürlich in
richtung olympia gehen werden und das
ziel olympia anfallen
beim klaren erfolg über den em gastgeber
überragte der starke schulter johannes
bitter mit 15 piraten morgen wartet
tschechien beim letzten spiel in wien
wird patrick wiencek wegen einer
knieverletzung die chance das spiel
morgen gegen tschechien live bei uns im
zdf ab 20 15
das wetter bringt wolken plus etwas
regen und es könnte auch glatt werden
die details hat gleich gunther tiersch
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
begrüßt sie marietta slomka und hier ist
morgen christian sievers dran
ich hatte heute ein bisschen knoten in
der zunge bitte das zu entschuldigen ich
wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen abend
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
und liebe zuschauer morgen wird es bei
uns drüber sein als heute und vor allen
dingen im norden an den küsten wird es
tatsächlich noch mal ein bisschen milder
aber insgesamt tagsüber kaum frost in
europa nur ganz im norden
höchsttemperaturen minus fünf grad in
skandinavien und bei uns haben wir den
frost natürlich auch aber nur nachts
minus 2 bis minus zehn grad aber im
norden bleibt es doch frostfrei hier
liegen die gewollten die ziehen dann
auch noch ins landesinnere ab und zu
kann es dann aus diesen wolken in der
nacht etwas regnen nach süden hin haben
den klaren himmel und nebel und morgen
vormittag könnte es am nordrand der
mittelgebirge auch mal glatt werden wenn
dieser leichte stuhl regen hier auf den
gefrorenen boden fällt im sauerland zum
beispiel auch im harz wahrscheinlich
ansonsten lockert im norden wieder auf
und das wird auch tagsüber am nachmittag
der fall sein dann zieht dieses
wolkenband aber langsam weiter richtung
meiner erzgebirge kann es immer noch ein
bisschen regnen und schneien es wird im
norden ein recht frischer kräftiger
nordwestwind dazu und bei den
temperaturen geht es rauf im norden also
auf sieben bis neun grad sonst bleibt es
bei etwa null bis sechs grad und es geht
ruhig weiter meist scheint die sonne
aber oftmals ist es auch neblig-trüb und
erst am samstag wird es eigentlich
ziemlich grau ich wünsche noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie's gut